THAT.
RAY WASHBURN, GOOD LUCK AND
GODSPEED.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: ALL OF A SUDDEN,
AMERICANS ARE LIVING IN A LESS
SECURE WORLD.
THEIR FAMILY IS ECONOMICALLY
VULNERABLE FOR THE REASONS YOU
JUST HEARD.
THEY ARE UNCERTAIN OF WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE.
IN ANY CRISIS LIKE THIS, IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT LEADERS HELP THE
PUBLIC FEEL SAFE, SECURE, AND
CONFIDENT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, AS DAILY
BRIEFINGS FROM THE PRESIDENT
HAVE BEEN HELPING, I THINK, IN
THAT WAY.
BUT IN SOME PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY, THE AUTHORITIES ARE
DOING JUST THE OPPOSITE.
IN LOS ANGELES, CLEVELAND, OTHER
CITIES, OFFICIALS HAVE BEGUN
RELEASING PRISONERS EARLY.
THEY WANT TO DO THAT ANYWAY, OF
COURSE, BUT NOW THEY CAN SAY IT
IS TO CONTAIN THE CORONAVIRUS.
THEY ARE NOT EXPLAIN HOW IT,
EXACTLY, THEY’RE JUST DOING IT.
CONGRESSMAN CONGRESSWOMAN
AYANNA PRESSLEY WANTS THEM TO
RELEASE THEIR OWN PRISONERS,
WATCH.
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT IS THE
GUIDANCE?
FOR THOSE INCARCERATED AND FOR
STAFF, AND THAT THE BOP USE
THEIR FULL POWERS, THINK NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME TO COMMUTE
SOME SENTENCES.
TO EXACT CLEMENCY, AND TO TAKE
CARE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE.
10% OF THOSE INCARCERATED ARE
OVER THE AGE OF 60 AND ALREADY
HAVE AN UNDERLYING CONDITION.
WE SHOULD BE USING COMPASSIONATE
RELEASE.
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
NOTICE THERE IS NO COMPASSION
FOR THE NORMAL PEOPLE HUDDLED IN
THEIR HOMES, SITTING THERE AS
THOUSANDS OF CRIMINALS ARE
RELEASED ON THE STREETS.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THEM.
SHE DOESN’T, THAT IS OBVIOUS.
BUT THERE IS MORE.
IN MANY CITIES, THEY ARE
ORDERING POLICE TO STOP
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC, TO STOP
DOING THEIR JOBS.
IN THE CITY OF PHILADELPHIA,
POLICE HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO
AVOID ARREST, EVEN FOR
SIGNIFICANT CRIMES, DRUG A
STENCH OFFENSES, PROSTITUION.
NOW BURGLARY GETTING A PASS.
BY PERSON COULD BREAK IN YOUR
HOME IN PHILADELPHIA AND NOT BE
ARRESTED.
INSTEAD, THEY WILL HAVE A SOME
AND LATER APPEARANCE AND SEND
THEM AWAY WITH A PRAYER THEY
WILL SHOW UP HERE IN FORT WORTH,
POLICE NO LONGER MAKE ARREST FOR
THEFT OVER $1,000 OR VANDALISM,
IN A MOMENT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
REALLY ON EDGE.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY, A
JURISDICTION WITH 9 MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING THERE, THE
SHERIFF’S DEPARTMENT ONLY
ARRESTING 60 PEOPLE A DAY.
A JURISDICTION IN 9 MILLION.
DOWN FROM 300 A DAY BEFORE
CORONAVIRUS.
ALL OF THIS IS EXASPERATING,
OBVIOUSLY, WHAT IS A VERY
VOLATILE SITUATION.
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED, MEANING
MILLIONS OF TEENAGERS WITH
NOTHING TO DO.
MOST OF THEM ARE GOOD KIDS,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT THEY ARE
TEENAGERS AND SOME WILL BE
TROUBLEMAKERS BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT THEY ARE LIKE.
YOUNG PEOPLE.
SO HOW WILL THEY BEHAVE WHEN
THEY REALIZE THEY CAN LOOP
STORES, STEAL CARS, OR TRASH
PUBLIC PLACES WITHOUT POLICE
RESPONDING TO IT?
WHAT YOU THINK THIS IS?
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS.
IT IS A RECIPE FOR CHAOS, AND
PEOPLE CAN FEEL IT.
THAT IS WAY ACROSS THE COUNTRY
GUN SALES HAVE SURGED IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THE MONTH.
IT’S RATIONAL.
THE POLICE AND IF THEY’RE NOT
GOING TO PROTECT YOU AND NOT DO
THEIR JOBS BECAUSE POLITICIANS
CONTROLLING THEM WON’T ALLOW
THEM, THEN RELEASING CRIMINALS
BACK INTO YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD, WHA
MEAN?
MEANS IT FALLS ON YOU TO PROTECT
YOURSELF AND YOUR FAMILY, BUT
YOU KNEW THAT.
BUT SUMMON POWER CAN’T HANDLE
THAT IDEA IF YOU’RE FOR THE
MAYOR OF CHAMPAIGN, ILLINOIS, IS
CLAIMING EMERGENCY POWERS,
INCLUDING SUSPENDING GUN SALES.
THE MAYOR OF NEW ORLEANS IS
CLAIMING MORE POWER.
SHE CLAIMS THAT SHE WANTS TO SHE
CAN BAN THE TRANSPORT OF
WEAPONS, TOO, EFFECTIVELY
ABOLISHING CONCEALED CARRY.
OBVIOUSLY, IT IS TEARING ME, BUT
IT IS DEEPER THAN THAT.
THE GOVERNMENT FAILS TO PROTECT
YOU, IT’S YOUR LIFE MORE
DANGEROUS, AND THEN IT TRIES TO
PREVENT YOU FROM PROTECTING
YOURSELF.
WHAT IS THAT?
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
IT IS REALLY OMINOUS.
A MEMBER OF THE NEW YORK STATE
ASSEMBLY AND RAN FOR NEW YORK
AMERICANS BILL de BLASIO,
WHICH SHE HAD ONE BACK BUT SHE
DIDN’T.
SHE IS HERE TONIGHT AND WE ARE
HAPPY.
NICOLE, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THIS
COMBINATION OF FACTORS, ALL OF
THEM CREATED BY OUR LEADERS,
THAT IT IS GOING TO MAKE OUR
STREETS MORE DANGEROUS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY DISGRACEFUL
THAT WE HAVE ELECTED OFFICIALS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY ENTERTAINING
THIS DURING A CRISIS EMERGENCY
SITUATION.
WE SHOULD BE INSTEAD CALLING
PEOPLE DOWN, TRY TO RELIEVE
THEIR ANXIETY, TO WORK WITH THEM
TO MAKE THEIR LIFE EASIER, NOT
PUT THEM IN A SITUATION WHERE
THEY ARE MORE SCARED OF WHAT MAY
POTENTIALLY BE HAPPENING.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE HEARING FROM
MEMBERS OF THE SQUAD AND MEMBERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
PUSHING FOR THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE, AND THE IDEA HERE
IN NEW YORK THAT WE WOULD EVEN
CONSIDER THIS WHEN, AS YOU KNOW,
I’VE BEEN ON YOUR SHOW MULTIPLE
TIMES TALKING ABOUT THIS
DANGEROUS -- THAT TOOK IN PLACE
JANUARY 1ST COME ALREADY BEING
RELEASED.
RIKERS ISLAND, SUSPECTED
MURDERERS, RAPISTS, GANG
MEMBERS, DRUG TRAFFICKERS, AND
CERTAINLY, NOT WHAT WE SHOULD BE
RELEASING BACK ON TO OUR STREETS
DURING THIS PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT TIME, OR EVER.
>> Tucker: SO I’M NOT A
PARANOID PERSON, I ASSUME GOOD
INTENT ON THE PEOPLE I DISAGREE
WITH.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WANT TO MAKE
THE COUNTRY BETTER.
BUT IF YOU SEE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO MAKE THE COUNTRY MORE
DANGEROUS AND MORE CHAOTIC, WHAT
ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
WHAT IS THE IDEA BEHIND THIS?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> I THINK IN MANY WAYS IT IS A
POWER GRAB.
I THINK THEY WANT TO CAUSE
DISRUPTION.
AND I THINK THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS VERY DISTURBING.
LOOK, I MAY BE RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW BUT I AM
CURRENTLY A STATE LEGISLATOR AND
I CAN TELL YOU IN MY COMMUNITY,
WE ARE WORKING TOGETHER,
BIPARTISAN FASHION, TO GET
THINGS DONE.
WHETHER IT BE LOOKING TO EXPAND
BEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE GOING TO BE ILL,
EXPANDING TESTING, MAKING SURE
WE ARE WORKING TO GIVE ECONOMIC
RELIEF TO BUSINESSES AND OUR
RESIDENTS, THAT SHOULD BE THE
FOCUS OF ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW,
NOW WOULD INDIVIDUALS LIKE THE
MEMBER THAT YOU PLAYED EARLIER,
IS TALKING ABOUT, JUST TO CREATE
CHAOS.
>> Tucker: SHE IS A DISGRACE.
THAT PERSON.
OF COURSE IT DOES.
AND TO USE A CRISIS TO PUSH YOUR
OWN CREEPY LITTLE HOBBYHORSE
THAT WILL MAKE AMERICA WORSE AND
PUT PEOPLE’S LIVES IN DANGER,
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED.
AYANNA PRESSLEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HERSELF.
I MEAN THAT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU GO TO
WASHINGTON.
>> HER SQUAD IN WASHINGTON.